[música]
เฮ
>> [música]
[música]
>> เฮ [música]
>> [música]
[música]
>> Olá, meus amores. Bom dia. Bom dia.
Estamos juntos aí em mais um encontro
das nossas revisões de direito civil. Já
tivemos três encontros sobre sucessões,
sobre família, sobre coisas e hoje nós
vamos ter um encontro muito muito
especial sobre responsabilidade civil.
Vamos embora conversar sobre um monte de
coisa maravig maravig que cai em prova.
Deixa eu falar, eu quero começar o
encontro de hoje mandando um beijo muito
especial para todo mundo que tá aí ao
vivo acompanhando a gente.
Bianca Robson, que fica falando mal de
direito civil, mas não me larga de jeito
nenhum.
Elisâela, Elvis, Lisane, Ana, Sara,
Janaína, Moara, Sérgio, Maria, Antônio,
um beijo para vocês. Ana Carolina,
Juliana de novo, Rosineid, um beijo.
Vamos embora. Dia 3 é logo ali, já
estamos ali no ponto, tá? Valéria, um
beijo, viu? Tomara que eu veja os
gatinhos passando pela tela do
computador. Hoje eles não vão passar
porque eles estão presos lá no gatilho
deles porque eu tô mexendo com pedreiro
aqui hoje e aí eu morro de medo deles
fugirem. Então eles ficam presos.
Cristian, já tô com saudade também, viu?
Um beijo, meu amor. Obrigada pela
presença. Mark, bom dia. Giovana Mateus,
bom dia. Bom dia. Hoje a gente vai
conversar sobre responsabilidade civil e
vamos fazer os nossos esquemas do
coração sobre o tema, né? O que que o
que que é bom a gente lembrar, alguns
artigos do Código Civil, temas
importantes, categoria pra gente, tá?
Vamos, vamos embora. Vamos começar o
nosso desenho. Deixa eu me preparar aqui
na meu no meu papelinho. Aliás,
a gente sempre faz um
como é que fala?
um uma ilustração, né, do tema da aula
hoje.
E eu quero colocar com vocês
um desenho para ilustrar
e a responsabilidade civil,
que é, na verdade,
uma ilustração são
sabe de quê,
gente? Que as imagens ruim que tem aqui,
sabe?
Que que vocês acham que ilustra bem a
responsabilidade civil? Um desenho para
ilustrar responsabilidade civil,
porque não existe responsabilidade civil
sem dano, né?
Não sei o que que eu coloco.
O simples fato de viver a vida pode
gerar a responsabilidade civil. E ah,
vou, já sei, adorei. Olha a imagem que
eu coloquei aqui. Olha aqui.
Oi, Roberta. Tão ficando, tão ficando aí
no no
disponíveis. Sim, pessoal. Eu recebi
algumas mensagens falando que a aula não
estava ficando disponível, mas tá.
É para tá.
Coloquei uma imagem aqui
que representa bem
nosso encontro. Dá uma olhada.
Uai, Roberta, por que que você colocou
esse doguinho aí com a menininha? Porque
imagina você que se você tá na sua casa
tranquilo, de boa, seu cachorro sai
correndo e morde a bunda de uma pessoa,
porque aqui em casa acontece isso.
Cleitinha
aqui é o terror e pânico da vizinhança.
Quando ela foge, ela morde todo mundo
que tá pela frente e ela vem sorrateira
pelas costas, tá? morde a bunda do povo.
Então,
a gente vai falar disso, de coisas do
dia a dia, da vida, que pode gerar
responsabilidade civil.
Mas o que que quando é que temos a
responsabilidade civil? Eh, quando é que
acontece esse fenômeno da
responsabilidade civil? Vamos ao nosso
material. Vamos começar as nossas
anotações. Então, vamos lá.
Quando a gente fala de responsabilidade
civil, só para deixar bem registrado,
nós estamos falando de alguém que tá
postulando
uma indenização.
Então, eu só tenho responsabilidade
civil quando alguém tá postulando
indenização. Essa é o fato. E alguém
postula indenização
porque existiu um fenômeno chamado dano.
Bem simples, né? Alguém postula
indenização
porque
aconteceu o dano. O dano ele pode ser de
variadas ordens. Pode ser um dano moral,
pode ser um dano material.
professora não sabe mais nem escrever,
né? Pode ser um dano material, pode ser
um dano
estético,
né? pode ser variados danos, dano moral,
dano material, dano estético. Então, eu
só falo em responsabilidade civil quando
aconteceu o dano. O dano, gente, é o
coração,
é o coração da responsabilidade civil.
Memoriza isso. Não existe
responsabilidade civil sem dano, tá?
Além da verdade, nós temos dois tipos de
responsabilidade civil. Dois,
dois tipos.
Nós temos a responsabilidade civil
contratual,
que é óbvio, decorre de uma relação de
contrato e a gente estuda essa
modalidade de responsabilidade civil no
campo do direito contratual e
obrigacional, não é o foco da nossa aula
de hoje. E nós temos a chamada
responsabilidade civil extra
contratual,
que é também chamada de responsabilidade
aquiliana.
Essa responsabilidade
é a que acontece pelo simples fato
de viver a vida, tá? Pelo simples fato
de viver a vida. Você pode causar um
dano a alguém pelo simples fato de viver
a vida. Professora, como assim? Imagina
que você saiu no seu carro e atropelou
uma pessoa. Imagina que o jarro de
planta que tá lá na varanda da sua casa
caiu lá embaixo na cabeça de alguém.
Imagina que você tá fazendo uma obra e
você causa o a rachadura na no imóvel do
vizinho. Imagina que o seu cachorro
fugiu de casa e mordeu uma pessoa. São
várias situações, né? E aí você tem a
responsabilidade pelo fato de viver a
vida. É essa modalidade que a gente vai
falar hoje, que a gente insere aqui o
artigo 186, 187, 188, 927
a 954
do Código Civil. Então o que a gente
trabalha aqui hoje é a responsabilidade
aquiliana. Agora, eu quero que você
lembre que sempre existe um prazo para
você cobrar o dano moral, o dano
material, o dano estético. Você sabe
muito bem que esse prazo é
prescricional, porque toda vez que a
gente fala de um alguém cobrando um
devedor por alguma coisa e nesse caso
pela responsabilidade civil, está
sujeita à pessoa a um prazo
prescricional.
Qual que é o prazo? No caso da
responsabilidade contratual, o STJ já se
manifestou
pelo fato dos 10 anos, aplicando o
artigo 205
do Código Civil.
A responsabilidade extracontratual, o
prazo é de 3 anos, aplicando o artigo
206,
parágrafo
terceiro, tá? Do Código Civil. Tudo bem?
Parágrafo terceiro do Código Civil.
Então, esse é o prazo prescricional
de cada uma.
É o prazo prional de cada uma. Além
disso, nós podemos contabilizar aqui no
nosso estudo dois tipos de
responsabilidade civil. Dois tipos.
a responsabilidade civil subjetiva e a
objetiva.
A objetiva é aquela responsabilidade
que tem incidência independentemente de
culpa e a subjetiva tem incidência a
depender da culpa.
Quando é que nós vamos falar em
responsabilidade objetiva? Isso já caiu
na prova.
Quando tiver previsto em lei, se tratar
de responsabilidade objetiva ou envolver
alguma atividade
de risco, tá? O autor do dano, ele
exerce uma atividade de risco. Nesse
caso, nós estamos diante da
responsabilidade objetiva, OK?
E a subjetiva, que é analisada com base
na culpa, é a regra
no direito civil, ou seja, o particular
responde via de regra com culpa.
Quando
a lei dispuser
não ser não ser subjetiva e sim objetiva
ou a atividade de risco por a atividade
desempenhada pelo causador do dano, aí a
gente vai ter uma responsabilidade
objetiva. Isso é o que consta no artigo
927,
parágrafo único, do Código Civil. Então,
de mais a mais, o que que temos aqui no
direito civil? O particular responde via
de regra por culpa. responderá ele
independentemente de culpa, ou seja,
haverá responsabilidade objetiva para o
particular quando a lei prevê, naquele
caso específico, se tratar de
responsabilidade objetiva ou a atividade
desenvolvida pelo causador do dano por
uma atividade de risco. Tá muito bem.
Agora, quais são os requisitos para que
a gente tenha a incidência efetiva da
responsabilidade civil? Muito importante
a gente falar sobre isso. Vamos lá. Se
quiser já dá o print nessa tela.
Vamos lá. Quais são os requisitos da
responsabilidade civil? Vou colocar aqui
bem destacado.
Requisitos
requisitos
da
responsabilidade civil. O que que eu
preciso para o juiz ordenar uma
indenização? O que que eu preciso para
afirmar que naquele caso específico tem
a responsabilidade civil? Eu preciso, eu
preciso categoricamente
de uma conduta humana. Vou colocar até
de laranja aqui, ó.
Conduta
humana. Eu preciso de dano.
A gente acabou de verificar que não
existe responsabilidade civil sem dano.
Eu preciso de nexo
causal
e eu preciso,
em alguns casos, de culpa. Esses são os
requisitos
ensejadores
da responsabilidade civil, tá? Esses são
os requisitos. que direcionam para uma
responsabilidade civil. Lembrando que o
coração da responsabilidade civil é o
dano. Eu posso ter tudo que você quiser,
conduta, anexo, culpa, mas se não tiver
dano, não tem responsabilidade civil.
Responsabilidade civil sem dano é um
corpo sem cabeça, não serve para nada.
Tá bom? Pois bem, quando a gente fala
desses conteúdos aqui, eu vou vou grifar
de uma maneira diferente. Quando a gente
fala desses conteúdos aqui, são os
conteúdos, são os requisitos, perdão, da
responsabilidade civil, né? É o que a
gente tá tratando aqui. Exatamente. São
os requisitos da responsabilidade civil.
Agora, se você tem, presta atenção
agora, se você tem, se você tem, vou
colocar de azul,
conduta humana,
nexo,
dano,
você tem uma forma de responsabilidade
civil.
Se você tem,
pera aí, gente, deixa eu arrumar um
negócio aqui. Pera aí. Deixa eu só ver
aqui um negócio aqui.
Vou fazer diferente para deixar
destacado.
Vou botar um grifo aqui
que vai ser melhor. Olha para cá.
Se você tem
conduta
dano inexo de causalidade, conduta, dano
inexo de causalidade,
você está diante
de uma modalidade específica de
responsabilidade civil.
Se você tem
conduta,
dano,
nexo e culpa,
você está diante de outra modalidade de
responsabilidade civil. Consegue
visualizar?
Quando eu tenho os primeiros requisitos,
eu tenho uma responsabilidade
objetiva.
Quando eu tenho conduta, dano nexo e
culpa, eu tenho uma responsabilidade
subjetiva.
Professora, eu quero artigos. A objetiva
pauta artigo 187,
a subjetiva,
artigo 186.
Atenção, aqui no direito civil a gente
não chama de dolo. Tudo pra gente é
culpa. Culpa por voluntariedade,
fez porque quis. Culpa por negligência,
imprudência e imperícia. A gente não
fala de dolo, porque o dolo é um termo
que pra gente aqui do civil é um vício
do negócio jurídico. É quando alguém
engana uma pessoa para celebrar um
contrato. Por exemplo, eu falo compra o
anel é de ouro e na verdade não é. Isso
é dolo. Eu tô enganando. Então no
direito civil a gente só usa a palavra
culpa. Culpa para falar, culpa. Culpa
mesmo. Culpa por voluntariedade, culpa
por negligência, imprudência em perícia.
A gente não fala dolo, tá? Não fala
dolo. E digo mais para você, a
indenização não é fixada pela medida da
culpa. A indenização é fixada pela
extensão do dano. Quanto maior o dano,
maior a indenização. Não é quanto maior
a culpa, maior a indenização. É quanto
maior o dano. Então a gente chama de
culpa, tá? Esses dois artigos aqui,
esses dois artigos eles vão
desaguar,
eles vão desaguar.
em um artigo específico
que é o artigo
que trabalha a responsabilidade civil,
tá? Então, a a responsabilidade civil
ela é na verdade uma equação matemática.
Ela é uma equação matemática. Como assim
uma equação matemática? Eu preciso
para minha equação matemática dar certo
e o resultado ser o juiz condenando a
indenizar pelo dano moral, pelo dano
material ou o que você quiser. Eu tenho
que ter um somatório de coisas. Que
coisa? Vamos lá. Eu preciso somar
conduta humana
mais
dano.
Aliás, vou botar na ordem aqui. Conduta
humana.
mais
nexo,
dano.
E dentro dessa conduta humana,
a gente analisa a culpa.
Se você soma tudo isso,
o resultado
será
a indenização. Então você consegue
visualizar, você consegue visualizar que
a indenização
ela é na verdade o resultado de um
somatório.
Consegue ver? Isso é o resultado de um
somatório. É uma equação matemática.
Então, para o resultado ser positivo, eu
preciso da incidência dessas situações.
Então, o que que eu tenho aqui? Eu
tenho, na verdade,
a o seguinte cenário,
a atividade humana
que causou um dano para alguém,
que é a conduta humana. dentro dessa
conduta humana, pode ser que sim, pode
ser que não. A gente analisa o fenômeno
culpa,
a gente tem um dano que foi causado
e a ligação.
E a ligação.
Oi, Mariana, um beijo, viu? Obrigada por
tá presente. Alícia também. Bom dia,
Élida. E a ligação aqui é
categoricamente
o nexo,
porque é o nexo de causalidade
que gera,
acho que eu fiz muito grande aqui, é o
nexo de causalidade
que gera
a ligação entre o dano
e a conduta humana.
Ou seja, a gente adota a teoria do nexo
direto. O nexo, ele significa que aquela
conduta humana foi a que causadora
direta do dano. Se você soma tudo isso
aqui, o resultado será exatamente o
dever de indenizar. É assim que
funciona,
entendeu? É assim que funciona. Então,
quando a gente fala do dever de
indenização, tem que tá muito expresso e
comprovado que eu tenho conduta humana.
Essa conduta humana foi causadora direta
do dano, ou seja, o nexo de causalidade.
E o juiz condena indenizar pelo dano
moral, pelo dano material, pelo dano
estético. Lembrando uma coisa que eu até
esqueci de falar aqui para você,
esse dano moral, dano material, isso
aqui já caiu no exame de ordem, então
vamos tomar nota disso.
Não tem mais dificuldade nenhuma. Esses
danos são cumuláveis,
tá? O STJ já assentou o entendimento
de que dano moral, dano estético não é a
mesma coisa, né? Isso aí já nem nem é
mais novidade, coisa antiga, inclusive.
E são danos cumuláveis. Eu posso fazer
um pedido de dano moral e dano estético
contra a mesma pessoa tranquilamente.
Tá bom? Belezura. Show de bola. Então
tá.
Memoriza essa cena aqui.
Essa cena aqui, tá vendo? Culpa, nexo,
dano. Eu vou copiar
e vou passar para um outro papel.
Olha
isso.
Olha isso. Se eu tenho o primeiro caso,
se eu tenho o primeiro caso,
o resultado é a indenização,
porque tá tudo bonitinho. Agora imagina
que tem um problema no meio do caminho
que gera isso aqui, ó. Ó.
o rompimento do nexo de causalidade. Tá
vendo?
Se acontece
o rompimento
do nexo de causalidade,
professora, que que eu vou ter aqui? Se
você tem o rompimento,
o rompimento do nexo de causalidade,
você vai ter um problema.
Porque se para ter o resultado final da
indenização eu tenho que ter tudo
bonitinho, você concorda comigo que se
houver o rompimento do nexo de
causalidade,
eu não terei
terei
a indenização?
Claro, se houver um rompimento no nexo
de causalidade, o juiz vai olhar e vai
falar assim: "Não tem obrigação de
indenizar".
E quais são as causas de rompimento do
nexo de causalidade? Quais são essas
situações? Vamos colocar aqui, ó. Quando
é que ocorre
o rompimento
do nexo causal?
Podemos afirmar que ao haver o
rompimento do nexo de causalidade, é o
mesmo que falar que
exclui a responsabilidade civil, porque
sim, exclui, né? Então, o rompimento do
nexo de causalidade
gera, que bosta, né, gente?
Eu com meu toque eterno aqui, o
rompimento do nexo de causalidade
gera a excludente da responsabilidade
civil.
Claro que sim.
excludente
de
responsabilidade civil. Porque se eu
afirmei para você no início da aula que
a responsabilidade civil é porque teve
um dano e eu tô buscando a indenização,
se você exclui a responsabilidade civil
é porque não haverá indenização.
Professora, quais são os casos de
excludente de responsabilidade civil?
São três. Vou botar até com coraçãozinho
para você não esquecer.
São três casos,
quais sejam. Vamos lá.
Culpa
ou fato
exclusivo
da vítima.
culpa
ou fato
exclusivo
de terceiro
portuito
ou
força
maior. Professora, me exemplifica isso.
Vou te exemplificar.
Olha só, imagina que eu tenho aqui a
Cleitinha, né, minha cachorra.
Aqui é uma gang, na verdade. Tá aqui a
Cleitinha. Aí
eu sei que ela morde.
Se eu chego com um carro, abro o portão,
tô chegando com um carro, abro o portão
e ela sai e morde uma pessoa, eu vou
responder por isso.
Ainda que eu não tenha tido culpa, o
artigo 936
estabelece que você responde
objetivamente. é um caso, é um exemplo
de responsabilidade objetiva do
particular pelos danos causados pelo
animal. Beleza? Então vou responder
objetivamente.
Agora
imagina você que eu tenho uma cleitinha
aqui dentro da minha casa e tem uma uma
placa bem ali no portão falando assim:
"Cachorro agressivo, louco, doido,
perturbado, não coloque a mão".
Aí você vai p coloca a mão no cachorro,
o cachorro te morde. Eu vou responder
por isso? Não, porque muito embora o meu
cachorro tenha te causado um dano aqui,
ó, tá vendo?
A culpa foi exclusivamente sua, então
não haverá o dever de indenizar,
tá?
Se eu estou com a cachorra dentro da
minha casa, vem um maluco desgovernado e
bate no portão da minha casa com o carro
dele, derruba o portão, a Cleitinha sai
e morde alguém.
Eu tenho, eu vou responder por isso?
Não, porque muito embora a minha
cachorra tenha causado um dano, foi uma
culpa ou fato exclusivo de um terceiro.
Eu não tenho nada a ver com isso.
Então, não haverá indenização, porque
isso rompe o nexo de causalidade. Rompeu
o nexo de causalidade exclui a
responsabilidade civil. Excluindo a
responsabilidade civil, não terá o dever
de indenizar,
tá? Não terá o dever de indenizar. Agora
imagina que eu tô na minha casa, tá? A
Cleitinha lá. no portão latino, dá um
raio por conta de uma chuva, derruba o
portão. O portão caiu no chão.
Ora, nesse caso específico,
foi força maior. A Cleitinha saiu,
mordeu uma pessoa. Embora a cachorra
seja minha e tenha causado um dano,
houve o Ah, que ódio. Houve o rompimento
do nexo de causalidade
por um fortuito ou força maior. Então,
muito cuidado, porque quando você exclui
a responsabilidade civil, o resultado, o
resultado categórico é esse aqui, ó. Ó,
não haverá
não haverá o dever de indenizar,
tá? Não haverá o dever de indenizar.
Perfeito. Agora, professora, nessa mesma
situação, eu posso confundir excludente
de responsabilidade civil. Olha isso
aqui. Eu dou na sua cara se você
confundir. Eu posso excluir,
eu posso confundir. Eu tenho o direito
de confundir excludente de
responsabilidade
civil
com excludente de ilicitude.
Não. Se você errar isso na sua prova, eu
dou na sua cara. Você não pode
confundir. Não pode confundir de jeito
nenhum.
De jeito nenhum.
Porque são coisas diferentes. Ah,
professora, a excludente de
responsabilidade civil exclui a
responsabilidade civil. A excludente de
ilicitude exclui a responsabilidade
civil, profe? Não necessariamente.
Depende. Depende. Depende de quê? Vamos
lá,
então. Vamos seguir nosso bonde aqui.
Olha lá. Depende de quê? Professora do
meu coração.
Preste atenção agora.
Vamos lá. Olha só. Imagina você
então que a excludente
excludente
de responsabilidade civil são aqueles
casos ali que a gente trabalhou.
Gente, é sério isso?
Eu
tenho toque, né? Vocês sabem. Então, é
excludente de responsabilidade civil. é
diferente,
diferente
de excludente
de
ilicitude.
É bem diferente de excludente de
Quando é que eu tenho uma excludente
de ilicitude? Quando é que eu tenho uma
excludente de ilicitude? Essas
excludentes estão previstas no artigo
188,
artigo 188.
Olha que legal, as excludentes de
ilicitude estão previstas no artigo 188.
Professora, quais são essas excludentes?
A gente vai observar aqui
as seguintes excludentes.
Vou botar aqui embaixo.
Não constituem atos ilícitos. Bom, a
gente já sabe que as excludentes de
ilicitude
são essas daqui, ó.
Não são? Vou copiar.
Olha
lá a diferença.
Culpa
ou fato exclusivo.
Botar de vermelhinho. Culpa ou fato
exclusivo da vítima?
Culpa ou fato exclusivo de terceiro.
Porto ou força maior? São as excludentes
de responsabilidade civil.
As excludentes de ilicitude são
são
legítima defesa,
que mais
exercício regular
de um direito
e
a deterioração
ou destruição de coisa alheia ou lesão.
a pessoa a fim de remover
perigo iminente.
Então, resumindo, resumindo a história,
o que que é considerado
excludente de ilicitude?
Resumindo a história, são três.
São três. Que que eu tenho aqui?
Legima defesa.
Exercício
regular.
de um direito.
Tá vendo a diferença?
E
deterioração, destruição de coisa alheia
ou lesão à pessoa a fim de remover
perigo iminente. Que que é isso?
Estado
de
necessidade,
que é quando você para evitar um mal
maior causa um dano a uma pessoa ou
lesão a alguém.
Por exemplo, para não, aquele caso
clássico, para não atropelar a criança
que se jogou na rua,
eh, como é que fala?
jogo o carro pro lado e bato no carro do
que tá passando. Eu causei um dano a
alguém, ao carro de alguém que tava
passando para não atropelar uma menina,
para evitar um a maior. Isso é estado de
necessidade. Não confunda estado de
necessidade com estado de perigo. Estado
de perigo é outra coisa diferente.
Estado de perigo é aquela situação lá do
negócio jurídico, quando alguém
necessitando de salvar a vida paga muito
muito caro para ser salvo. é estado de
perigo, é vício do negócio jurídico. A
gente vai falar no nosso último
encontro, mas aqui a gente tem uma
excludente de ilicitude,
tá? Na no estado de necessidade.
Professora, se acontecer
se acontecer
uma excludente de ilicitude,
se acontecer uma excludente de
ilicitude, eu tenho o dever de
indenizar,
como é que fica essa história? Vamos
pegar tudo aqui. Bora. Bora.
Se acontecer uma excludente de
ilicitude, que são essas aqui, que você
já sabe,
rompe a responsabilidade civil? Claro
que não. Claro que não. Não, não, não.
Por quê? Porque só rompe a
responsabilidade civil esses casos que a
gente comentou. culpa ou fato exclusivo
da vítima, culpa ou fato exclusivo de
terceiro, fortuto ou força maior. Nesse
caso aqui, a excludente de ilicitude
é uma situação que pode ou não ter, pode
ou não ter indenização. Como que a gente
vai observar isso? Vamos lá. Quando a
gente tem, ó, a caneta mágica aqui.
Horrível essa caneta mágica. Não gostei.
Não gostei.
Vamos ver aqui essa caneta mágica aqui.
Uma porcaria, né? Também
vou pegar a canetinha normal mesmo de
sempre.
O meu lápis,
o meu lápis fez foi sumir aqui.
Aqui o meu lápis deslachando.
Vamos lá meu lápis. Vamos lá.
aqui
exclui obrigatoriamente
o dever de indenizar.
Que que você me diz? Exclui
obrigatoriamente o dever de indenizar?
Não. Não exclui obrigatoriamente o dever
de indenizar. Afinal de contas, nós não
estamos diante de uma
excludente de responsabilidade civil.
Então aqui, ó,
pode
ou não
pode ou não
ter
indenização.
Pode ou não ter indenização.
Professora, pode me dizer? O programa é
o PowerPoint mesmo, normal. Pode ou não
ter indenização, tá, professora? aqui,
tendo ou não indenização, eu vou ter
indenização quando? A gente vai
adicionar aqui dois artigos, que é o 929
e o 930.
Seguinte, é,
vou copiar aqui para você
929 e 930. Eu vou adicionar aqui agora.
Vai
ficar bem lindo esse material, gente.
Bem lindo mesmo. Olha só o 929.
Olha lá.
Então, nós temos aqui dois artigos
importantes, 929
e 930.
O 929 diz o seguinte: "A pessoa lesada
ou o dono da coisa, no caso do inciso
dois, que que é o inciso dois? estado de
necessidade
não forem culpados do perigo, eles
possuem direito à indenização.
Vou te dar uma uma um bizu já já. No
caso do inciso dois, de novo, no caso do
inciso dois, se o perigo ocorrer por
culpa de terceiro, contra este terá o
autor do dano, ação regressiva.
Então aqui pode ou não ter reparação.
Pode ou não ter reparação. Professora,
como que eu vou resolver isso? Pode ou
não ter reparação. Eu vou fazer o
seguinte, eu vou puxar isso aqui mais
para cá.
pode ou não ter reparação. Como que eu
vou resolver isso? Respondendo uma
pergunta muito básica.
Você vai responder assim, ó. Quem
sofreu o dano
foi
quem
causou
o problema.
É basicamente o que consta do 929 e 930.
Quem sofreu dano foi quem causou o
problema. Você tem duas opções de
resposta
e para as duas opções de resposta,
você tem duas
possibilidades.
Se você responder para mim que sim,
quem sofreu dano foi quem causou o
problema, essa pessoa não tem
indenização.
Se você responder para mim que não, vou
botar só um szinho.
Então vamos lá. Se você responder para
mim que sim, quem sofreu o dano foi quem
causou o problema, não indeniza.
Se quem
sofreu dano não foi o causador do
problema,
sim, você indeniza. Tá vendo? Então é só
você responder esse questionamento
que você resolve
a Celuma.
Professora, pelo amor de Deus, Jorge
Mateus,
me ajuda.
Vamos lá. Vou copiar isso aqui.
Dá o print nessa tela. Tela linda dessa
que nos da senhora.
E vamos
adicionar aqui.
Foi isso que a gente combinou, não foi?
Foi, não foi? Pois muito que bem. Olha
isso.
Quem sofreu dano foi quem causou o
problema. Vamos aos casos.
Vamos aqui aos nossos casos.
Imagina você
esse caso número um que você com
certeza, se você tá estudando paraa
prova, você já fez um caso desse. Vamos
lá.
Caso número um.
Imagina que tá aqui
o
João.
Olha o desenho
com a filha dele,
Mariezinha.
Tá, tá aqui com a Mariazinha. Ele tá
rente
a uma pista.
Gente, olha isso.
Olha isso.
Bem aqui.
Bem aqui
vem o carro.
Tô falando agora, Carlos, como é que cai
na prova. Para eu te explicar como é que
cai na prova, eu tenho que te explicar o
conteúdo. Não consigo fazer diferente.
Então, olha só,
tá aqui
dois cartos.
Tá vendo? Os carros estão indo pra
frente. De repente,
de repente esse carro azul, vamos
colocar aqui, esse carro azul aqui é da
Lorena, professora Lorena. E esse carro
roxo aqui é da professora Patrícia,
da Pat.
De repente, olha a merda, essa menina
vem e se joga na pista.
Patrícia Lorena, na verdade, que vem
vindo aqui, tá vendo?
Para não atropelar a menina, joga o
carro pro lado e bate no carro da
Patrícia.
A pergunta é:
Lorena causou um dano
para a Patrícia? Porque a Lorena bateu
no carro da Patrícia.
A Lorena vai indenizar a Patrícia? Você
concorda que nesse caso nós temos
categoricamente um estado
de
necessidade?
Sim, porque olha lá, eu estou causando
um dano para alguém para evitar um mal
maior, para remover um perigo iminente.
Então, a Lorena causou um dano pra
Patrícia. Minha pergunta é: Lorena tem
que indenizar a Patrícia? Você vai
responder a pergunta que a gente colocou
aqui. Quem sofreu o dano foi quem causou
o problema. Vamos lá. Quem sofreu o dano
foi a Patrícia. Foi a Patrícia.
Foi a Patrícia que causou o problema.
Não, não foi a Patrícia. Então, sim, ela
será indenizada. Então, a Lorena
indeniza a Patrícia.
Então aqui, ó, sim indeniza, entendeu?
Aqui sim indeniza.
Mas, professora, a Lorena só bateu o
carro porque a Mariazinha se jogou na
pista
e quem tinha que tá tomando conta da
Marizzinha é o João. Bom, a Lorena
indeniza a Patrícia. E aí a gente volta
aqui, ó. Ó, se o perigo ocorrer por
culpa de terceiro, que nesse caso aqui
foi o João, contra este terá o autor da
ação do dano, ação regressiva. Então, a
Lorena indeniza a Patrícia e age em
regresso contra o
contra o João.
Olha que sensacional esse exemplo.
Olha que sensacional.
Vou te dar um outro exemplo. Vamos lá.
Vamos fazer uma linhazinha aqui
para dividir.
Caso dois. Ficou horrível, né?
Vamos botar aqui, ó. Caso dois.
Caso dois.
Imagina você
que aqui
tá o shopping, né? Tá aqui o shopping.
Botar aqui assim.
Tá aqui o shopping
bonitinho.
Shopping.
Bem aqui na frente do shopping. Eu não
sou muito boa de desenho, mas a gente
tenta, né, gente? Bem aqui na frente do
shopping tem as vagas de garagem.
Tá? Tem as vagas de garagem,
tem
um carro
estacionado bem aqui. E é assim que a
banca vai te cobrar, porque ela vai te
dar um caso concreto para você resolver.
Tá aqui a Kombi do João estacionado.
Tá aqui a combi do João estacionado.
Vem vindo.
Vou pegar aqui.
Nossa, ficou sem a cabeça.
Hum.
va a cabeça do homem, né?
Vem vindo o João com a filha Mariazinha
dele,
tá andando no estacionamento.
Daí a pouco vem
a Lorena
com a sua Ferrari. Lorena tá andando no
estacionamento procurando vaga.
Ah,
tá vendo?
Do nada a Mariazinha se joga na pista.
Lorena, para evitar,
pega o carro, vira o carro e bate no
carro do próprio João.
No carro do próprio João. Então, o João
é o dono do carro que foi batido.
Lorena causou um dano pro João,
concorda? Lorena causou um dano
para o próprio João. A Lorena vai
indenizar o João? Você vai responder a
pergunta. Quem sofreu o dano foi quem
causou o problema? Quem sofreu o dano
foi o João. Foi ele que causou o
problema? Foi, porque foi ele que não
controlou a própria filha. Então, nesse
caso, a Lorena Denisa, sim ou não?
Não, não indeniza.
É assim que você vai analisar na prova.
Vou te dar um exemplo três.
Se não indeniza, não tem regresso, né?
Vamos aqui pro exemplo três.
Exemplo três.
Imagina agora que a Kombi é da Pat.
Patrícia parou a combi dela lá no
estacionamento
e deixou
num sol escaldante de rachar o coquinho
o carro
e simplesmente
dentro do carro.
Vou botar de rosinha aqui para você
visualizar.
Dentro do carro tem
o cachorrinho. Tá vendo ele aqui? Dentro
do carro tem o cachorrinho. O carro é da
Patrícia.
O carro é da Pat. A van, a Kombi aqui é
da Pat. E a Pat
deixou, né, a van ali
estacionada no sol, saiu, foi no mercado
fazer compras e deixou o cachorro lá
dentro.
De repente vem
Lorena,
vem Lorena
com um pedaço de pau
maior que ela.
Quebra o vidro.
Vou fazer aqui de verde para você
visualizar melhor. Quebra o vidro da
Kombi e tira o cachorrinho.
Veja,
Loris causou um dano pra Patrícia, não
foi?
Causou um dano para Patrícia. A minha
pergunta é: Lorena vai indenizar a
Patrícia?
É só você responder. Quem sofreu o dano
que foi a Lorena. Mentira. Quem sofreu
dano, que foi a Patrícia, foi quem
causou o problema. Ora, quem sofreu dano
foi a Patrícia e quem largou o cachorro
dentro da Kombe foi a própria Patrícia.
Então aqui indeniza ou não indeniza?
Não indeniza.
Não indeniza. Claro que não.
OK.
Vamos para um caso quatro. que foi
objeto da prova da OAB.
Caso quatro.
Olha lá,
caso quatro.
Patrícia,
a Patrícia
pediu emprestada
a bike da Lorena. Quem tá fazendo
questão de prova sabe que essa questão
foi cobrada pela FGV.
Tá.
Então vamos lá. Patrícia pegou a bike da
Loren emprestada.
Essa bike custa R$ 50.000.
Uma bike super cara.
E aí,
Patrícia?
Tá lá andando
na bike lá de boa.
Vou até botar aqui, ó.
Patrícia tá lá andando na bike dela, tá?
passeando em todos os lugares.
Ah, passeando, tá lá andando
e ela à vista
o demônio do João com uma faca
indo
para uma agressão
à namorada dele.
Maria,
sabe o que que el a Patrícia faz? A Pat
tá andando na bicicleta da Lorena, que
custa R$ 50.000.
Pat pega,
acelera, vem lá da caixa prego, acelera
bem muito forte, p, joga a bicicleta em
cima do João,
consegue salvar a Maria.
Isso aqui é um caso de quê?
Legítima
defesa.
Salvou a Maria. Mas deixa eu te falar, a
bicicleta se acabou.
A bicicleta se acabou.
Se acabou.
Minha pergunta é,
Patrícia vai ter que indenizar Lorena
nos 50.000 da bicicleta?
É só você responder: quem sofreu o dano,
que foi a Lorena, foi quem causou o
problema?
Não. Então,
sim, indeniza.
Mas se a Patrícia pagar os 50.000 paraa
Lorena, ela pode agir em regresso contra
quem?
Eu quero que você me responda aí no
chat. Ela vai agir em regresso contra
quem? Pelo amor de Deus,
porque nos outros casos a gente já viu
que quando indenizou agiu em regresso
contra o causador do dano.
Na legítima defesa, e essa foi uma
questão da prova da OAB. na legítima
defesa. Olha lá, quando a gente fala de
ação regressiva, a galera aí que foi meu
aluno, já tá todo mundo acertando.
Essa ação competirá contra aquele em
defesa de quem se causou o dano. Então,
na legítima defesa, ação regressiva
é contra a
Maria. Perfeito. Perfeito. Vocês estão
demais.
Demais, demais, demais.
OK. Dá o print nessa tela. Vamos seguir
o bonde. Vamos lá.
Você lembra
quem são os incapazes?
Quem são os incapazes?
Nós temos
dois tipos de incapazes.
Dois,
O absolutamente incapaz
e o relativamente incapaz.
E quem são essas pessoas hoje? O único,
o único absolutamente incapaz que nós
temos
é o menor de
16 anos. Tá lá no artigo terceiro do
Código Civil. E quem são os
relativamente incapazes?
Os que têm entre 16
e 18 anos.
Quem mais?
Os ébrios
habituais, que são os alcólatras.
Quem mais? Os viciados intóxicos.
Quem mais?
Quem
não
manifesta
vontade
e os
pródigos, que são aqueles que gastam
compulsivamente e dilapidam seus
respectivos patrimônios.
Tudo bem?
O que que a gente vai fazer?
A gente vai observar
aqui o seguinte.
Imagina que uma pessoa incapaz,
seja absolutamente
ou seja relativamente,
causou um dano.
Tipo, o menino tá lá jogando bola
e quebrou
a a o vidro
da casa
de alguém.
Ou seja, um menino causou um dano.
O menino causou um dano para um
terceiro. Um incapaz. A pergunta é: o
incapaz responde pelos danos que ele
causar a alguém? O que que você me diz?
A pessoa que é incapaz responde pelos
prejuízos que causar?
Sobre a responsabilidade civil do
incapaz, nós temos
o artigo
928,
que diz o seguinte:
"O incapaz, olha isso, o incapaz
responde
pelos prejuízos que ele causar,
se as pessoas por ele responsáveis
não tiverem obrigação de fazer ou não
dispuser de meio suficiente. Então o o o
incapaz ele pode responder, só que na
verdade ele só vai responder se o
representante dele não responder. Então,
a responsabilidade dos incapazes, eu
quero que você memorize isso, ela é subs
[roncando]
diária, ou seja,
primeiro, quem tá na linha de frente é o
representante.
Se o representante
não tiver condição ou não tiver
obrigação naquele caso de fazer,
aí eu vou para quem? Para o próprio
incapaz. Então eu só cobro do incapaz se
o representante não tiver condição. Isso
já caiu na prova da OAB. O examinador
não soube elaborar a questão, teve que
anular a questão. Então pode ser que uma
questão desse tipo volte para você aí
num novo formato, tá bom?
Então, a responsabilidade do incapaz é
uma responsabilidade
eh subsidiária. Eu quero que você preste
muita atenção
nessa palavra aqui, tá? É subsidiária,
pelo amor de Deus.
E essa criaturinha aqui?
Quer ver?
Vou colocar para você aqui.
E essas criaturinhas que tanto amamos
quando atacam alguém?
Olha a cara disso aqui, gente. Olha isso
aqui.
Como que fica a responsabilidade?
pelo fato do animal,
responsabilidade
pelo fato do animal. Aqui a gente tem um
artigo que é o artigo 936.
Esse artigo diz o seguinte,
vou botar ele aqui para você, ó.
Ó,
o 936 diz o seguinte:
o dono,
o dono
ou o detentor, tipo, se o seu cachorro
tiver com adestrador, sabe? O dono ou o
detentor
do animal ressarcirá o dano por este
causado se não provar culpa da vítima ou
força maior. O que que tá dizendo esse
artigo? Esse artigo tá dizendo que a
responsabilidade pelo fato do animal é
objetiva,
ou seja, não depende de culpa. Mas você
tem como excluir a responsabilidade
civil
se você comprovar
culpa ou fato exclusivo da vítima, por
exemplo. Tá vendo? Você tem como excluir
a responsabilidade civil. Então, a
responsabilidade é objetiva, mas você
pode comprovar que tudo decorreu de
culpa da vítima ou de força maior, que
são as ex clentes
de responsabilidade
civil. Lembra que eu falei para você da
Cleitinha aqui em casa? Eu falei assim:
"Eh, imagina
você que a Cleitinha, eu abro o portão,
ela sai e morde uma pessoa." Eu vou
responder.
Se a Cleitinha tá lá no portão latindo e
você põe a mão nela, eu já não vou
responder, porque muito embora ela tenha
mordido você, a culpa é exclusivamente
sua. Foi você que colocou a mão aqui
dentro e ela te atacou. Eu tenho nada
que ver com isso, nada.
Tá? Ou se caiu um raio no portão,
derrubou o portão e ela saiu e mordeu
uma pessoa.
Tá bom?
Então aqui a gente tem o fato do animal.
Dá o print nessa tela. Então,
responsabilidade pelo fato do animal é
do dono ou do detentor. Então, se o meu
cachorro estiver com o adestrador, aí o
adestrador também responde. Mas eu
também vou responder, né? Porque eu dei
a ordem pro adestrador, então também
posso responder.
Vamos lá, vamos para um outro exemplo.
Esse aqui
é categoria de prova.
Tá aqui o chão. Quem é meu aluno já viu
esse desenho 1 milhão de vezes. Tá aqui
o chão. Bem aqui
tem um prédio.
E aqui
tem outro prédio.
Vou até fazer uma porta diferente nesse.
Nesse primeiro prédio aqui,
uma pasilha
do revestimento, um pedaço do
revestimento do prédio,
se desprendeu e caiu
na cabeça de uma pessoa que tava
passando.
é o sangue.
Nesse caso, nós temos a problemática
do edifício em ruína.
Tá vendo? Um pedaço do prédio caiu na
cabeça da pessoa.
Situação diferente
é a do segundo prédio.
Imagina você, imagina você
que esse vizinho aqui sempre coloca o
jarro de planta na varanda.
Vamos dar uma lupa aqui,
tá? Ele coloca o jarro de planta na
varanda
e aí esse jarro caiu
na cabeça de uma pessoa que tava
passando
e machucou a pessoa.
Como é que fica essa história?
Fala aí para mim. É muito sangue, gente.
[risadas]
É muito sangue.
Esse segundo caso é a responsabilidade
por coisas
caídas,
defenestradas,
arremessadas.
Nós temos dois artigos diferentes.
Dois artigos diferentes.
Artigo 937
e artigo
938.
O artigo,
o artigo
não tinha tantos detalhes do sangue.
O artigo
diz o seguinte:
O dono do edifício,
o dono do edifício
responde pelos danos que resultarem de
sua ruína. Então, na responsabilidade
pela ruína, quem responde é o dono do
prédio.
É o dono.
Diferente das coisas caídas ou
arremessadas, porque aqui
as coisas caídas ou arremessadas
responde aquele que habitar o prédio.
Quem habita não é necessariamente o
dono. Pode ser, pode ser o dono,
pode ser quem alugou, que é o locatário,
pode ser quem tem o imóvel emprestado,
que é o comodário.
Então, é quem habitar
na ruína é o dono. E um detalhe do
coração, para os dois casos,
a responsabilidade é
objetiva.
Para os dois casos, a responsabilidade é
objetiva
para os dois casos,
objetiva. Olha que sensacional.
OK.
Tudo bem, Roberta? No caso das coisas
caídas, se não der para descobrir de
onde o jarro caiu, porque ninguém anda
embaixo do prédio.
Ninguém anda embaixo do prédio
olhando para cima. Ninguém. Então, caiu
o jard de planta lá na minha cabeça.
Caiu lá o jard de planta na minha
cabeça.
Aí
eu não sei de onde
caiu,
mas
dá para descobrir. Aí você vai procurar
aquele que habita aquela unidade. Se não
der para saber,
todo condomínio responde. Nesse caso
aqui, deixa eu arrumar esse desenho
aqui, que eu tenho toque, né, gente?
Vocês sabem disso, então não é segredo
para ninguém.
Nesse segundo caso aqui, se não der para
saber de onde a coisa foi
arremessada,
o condomínio
responde. E o condomínio responde pela
teoria da causalidade
alternativa,
tá? Todo condomínio responde pela teoria
da causalidade alternativa.
Maravilhoso.
Olha essa questão que caiu no exame de
ordem, que foi uma questão para
confundir a cabeça da pessoa mesmo.
Olha só,
foi mais ou menos assim, como disse
Chicó, né? Não sei, só sei que foi
assim. Olha como foi essa questão. A
questão dizia assim,
vou até colocar aqui para você
ter cuidado, atenção,
porque isso aqui foi a cobrança da
questão.
Olha o que que dizia a questão. Foi mais
ou menos assim.
A sociedade
empresarial
X Y Z
alugou
o edifício
de
propriedade
da
sociedade
Z YX.
Diz aqui a questão que no dia
9/10,
não, a questão não é nesses termos, tá?
É, foi mais ou menos assim, despencou,
despencou
um jarro.
de planta
no
carro
do
João.
Ora, nesse caso, quem é que responde?
Se despencou
o jarro de planta, a gente vai aplicar o
artigo 938,
que é o defenestramento, as coisas
caídas. Quem responde, quem habita, né?
Responderá aquele que habitar o prédio.
Quem é que tá habitando nesse exemplo?
Ora, eu tenho a sociedade X Y Z.
que é locatária
e a propriedade
é da sociedade ZYX.
Proprietário.
Se eu tô falando de coisa caída,
responde quem? responde. Quem
responderá
a X Y Z, porque é quem está
habitando.
Agora, se a pergunta fosse,
se a pergunta fosse,
[limpando a garganta]
se a pergunta fosse
no dia 9
do 10,
despencou
uma placa
de concreto
da
prédio.
Quem responde?
Nesse caso aqui, se despencou uma placa
de concreto, eu aplico o 937,
que é a responsabilidade pela ruína.
Quem responde aqui
nesse segundo caso
responderá a sociedade Z YX, porque ela
é a dona, tá vendo? Então a banca
colocou X Y Z, Z Yx para confundir o
candidato.
Isso foi uma coisa cobrada na prova.
OK.
Certo,
Maravig Gold.
Vamos dar o print nas telas de hoje.
Ai, que coisa linda, né? Mais um
encontro efetivo.
Fico muito feliz pelos nossos encontros
darem certo. A gente conversa sobre
muita coisa.
Olha aí, dá o print aí na tela.
Print.
Responsabilidade civil.
Diferença de contratual e
extracontratual. Prazo de prescrição.
Requisitos.
Vai dando print excludente
de responsabilidade, né?
Excludente de responsabilidade e
excludente de ilicitude.
As excludentes de licitude, como que
você vai resolver se cair na sua prova?
A questão do dano, do estado de
necessidade, da legítima defesa e a ação
regressiva,
responsabilidade dos incapazes, que é
sempre subsidiária, equitativa,
responsabilidade pelo fato do animal,
responsabilidade pela ruína, pelas
coisas caídas.
a questão da ruína e das coisas caídas,
como já foi cobrado em prova.
E é isso, gente. Eu agradeço muito a
participação de vocês hoje. Já tô
começando a ficar sem voz porque nessa
reta final a gente já começa a ficar
meio maluco, né? e
a voz cansando. Mas é sofrido para todo
mundo, é sofrido para você, é sofrido
pros seus profs, mas a gente tá junto e
a gente vai seguir e vai dar certo,
porque nós temos um objetivo e esse
objetivo vai ser cumprido. O nosso
objetivo é a sua aprovação e o seu
objetivo é a conquista do seu sonho. A
gente não pode eh querer cobrar da vida
quando a gente não faz a nossa parte.
Eu sei, eu sei. É difícil, é cansativo,
é solitário.
Às vezes bate aquela sensação de
desesperança,
mas a gente tem que seguir porque a
gente não tem opção. Os dias vão passar
a gente agindo ou não. É super normal.
ter um dia ou outro que você vai falar:
"Dane-se, eu não quero nada, não vou
fazer nada, vou ficar embaixo do meu
cobertor morrendo o dia inteiro." Super
normal. por aqui acontece sempre,
mas no dia seguinte a gente tem que
levantar, colocar o pé no chão, ainda
que seja difícil, e seguir em frente,
porque
a nossa vida sempre tem algo
surpreendente para nós, mas a gente
precisa lutar por isso,
porque aquela máxima do direito, né? O
direito não socorre aos que dormem. A
vida também não socorre quem só dorme.
Beijo para vocês. Fiquem bem,
respira fundo e segue. Vai, vai, que o
que tiver que ser seu será. Beijo,
beijo. Tchau para vocês. Qualquer coisa,
tô lá no Instagram, @robertakeiroz e
aqui no YouTube com direito, como nunca
se viu no meu canal. Beijo, beijo.
[música]